le millésime 83 est arrivé il ne s'agit
pas de champagne mais d'un autre produit
bien français qui coûte beaucoup plus
cher
la haute couture les collections
commence à paris dans la traditionnelle
effervescence des acheteurs des copieurs
des journalistes et des photographes de
superbe créature vêtue dévoile les
trouvailles des créateurs france roche
jacques aubertin verdun puissesseau ont
choisi de nous faire admirer les
collections avec l'oeil du profane
la voilà elle est arrivée la mode hiver
sur un skateboard et en body stocking de
laine par 38 à londres je préfère ne pas
dire combien en se liant ce body
stocking et pour court n 1 bat pour le
corps à condition bien sûr que le corps
le supportent et que le body n'est pas
trop à supporter avec une veste en
vinyle la voilà équipé pour noël pensent
les patineurs qui eux n'ont pas besoin
de classe sauf dans leur verre
pendant qu'ils se trompent les pieds
dans l'eau ça ne les dérange pas
vraiment que des demoiselles portent
quelques kilos de fourrure sur des
justaucorps de l'aisne tels que les a
vus frédéric castets pour dior fourrure
sur des brand dans des bosquets des
demoiselles venues de norvège ou du
kenya exact devant les caméras la mode
de paris pour deux mille francs l'heure
ils peuvent accepter ce genre de pique
nique en forme de strip tease en tee
shirt humide et en short touristique
on apprend dans la rue sur la haute
couture autant que les ambassadrices et
princesses qui voit défiler dans des
salons dorés et 50 millions de robes ans
un jour
si c'est plus démocratique et on en
prime ces grands oubliés les cameramen
qui mêlent l'utile à l'agréable vous
habiter chez mes parents je connais un
bistrot sympa glisse entre deux plants
tintin et nanard overtime puissesseau
pour les dames ausy grid et autres
sabrina à part ça boulot boulot
grâce à eux on sera partout que l'hiver
prochain la femme sera toujours la femme
bien sûr mais aura la taille mince si
elle peut cardin l'exil des manteaux
très large
austérité oblige jean patou qu'elle
verra la vie en noir avec hanae mori
givenchy ou paco rabanne
ou en rouge rouge vermillon et lapidus
réunis vous rayer vu par lepage rouge
bon genre puisque chamelle
et rouge gala signé faible
les jupes seront asymétrique venait 30
sauf pour le british open ou les petites
écossaise nous la roue
le shérif
de la roche enfin sur les têtes des
chapeaux d'un micro qui prouveront
commune scotia femme peut être le de
l'homme shdm a remis ces dames ne sont
peut-être pas convaincu ni the gens
dansent a encore tout à l'âge mais on
lui 2
cette nuit ils vont arriver